my first journey with G fuel I sought them out
because I already used their product we struck
a deal and then I renegotiated to get less money
from them and get more G Fuel and then I decided
I want even lesser lesser lesser money to get
even more G fuel all right let's put this in the
fridge yeah use our promo code in the in the
description come on [Music] oh god I've lost my
[Music] mind ladies and gentlemen we just learned
that this is not the final episode of season 1 and
Roxy has to maneuver her entire life schedule next
week so we can film it I'm going to try don't be
like Coy he always puts me in this position for
the final episodes I you did okay this is totally
my fault first off I'm going to let everyone know
the 180 that just happened leave a like people
that'd be awesome hey also subscribe and click
that notification Bell to get notified when our
reaction is up for episode something or another
prepper I think you edited these and I think you
did a great job full length Reaction watch long
where you single with your own copy of hasell that
is for our super sexy rejects how you do patreon p
the Wonder just looks at me when I'm doing the
intro I could just see her looking and it just
makes me so uncomfortable like I don't like when
people look at me I don't like eye contact all
right eye contact is going to ruin my life I feel
like people can see how puny I really am on the
inside when people look at me in the eyes and
uh yeah let's watch the show let's have a good
time I'm actually excited to know more about
vaggie me too we don't know anything about
vaggie vagy I don't know no saggy vaggy
vaggie I have a light jacket flat jacket
and rain jacket does it rain in Heaven Charlie
you're only going to heaven for a few hours yeah
why you dodging Heaven it's our last chance to
convince Heaven a soul can be redeemed yeah I
wish I could come sweetie sweetie but I have
that thing what thing the thing with God I'm
such a bad liar what is going on veggy what
did she do to get to hell I need you there
with me fine why do these last two episodes
Sly make it so clear that they're partners
look at this maybe they got feedback yeah
for people like us it's who happened to me
and the answer is everyone twice Val had
me working 16 hours straight on a whim no
jeez what the is with that wall what up oh my God
she's back [__] Cherry bom CH Cherry not since
the pilot you've been texting me a depressing
[__] all day figured we could tear [__] up
like old times here hold this oh my God oh my
God nope give me that I love seeing Jerry I'm
she played hot potato with it I need to pass
out oh you can sleep when you're double Dead
come on what you really need is a recharge a
responsible night on the town that is a great
idea buzz kill so nice to meet one of Angel's
Friends he never brings anyone around wonder
why yeah me too anyway she's so innocent hi
everyone Angel and his friend are taking you
all out for a night of fun and relaxation wait
I am only here for and O never mind let's go
sure they have the best time tonight anyway the
portal to heaven should be opening right about
I mean the best time tonight would probably
be some really bad things yeah was not good
phrasing if it isn't my arch nemesis have you
come to I'm going out with I Angel and I got to
drag your sorry asses along you and me are going
out like for fun I I didn't think this would ever
happen what do I wear don't [__] touch me
a mon head I didn't really like him when he
first showed up in the show but ever since he
started checking in this hotel it's been so
funny isn't that amazing yep interesting design
what is this Heaven wow it's generic Heaven chai
I'm not seeing you on my list um my dad got
me to this meeting so maybe try Lucifer yeah
yikes cuz I think you might be a little lost
no uh we're we're here for a meeting oh no St
Peter we can take it from here it is St Peter
okay I'm Sarah the high seraphim of Heaven hi
I'm Emily the other seraphim though you can
call me m they're going to get along great
yeah there's got to be a Twist to it it's got
to be more cool design on them though [Music]
my this feels like trolls [Music] does oh my
god this is my jam how did a crocodile get to
heaven that crocodile ate no one never hey hey
don't judge maybe it's a vegetarian Croc [Music]
wow her voice is killer
[Music] too this is all a
lie it's a lie oh no what's behind the curtain I
don't like this holy [__] balls am I seeing what
I think I'm seeing what is is she doing here how
did she even get up here who cares like the mean
girls in school waiting for the extermination
what was the seraphim's one rule no one but the
Exorcist can know about the exterminations I know
fine that's right you got to Kill The Exorcist but
they know how to kill the Exorcist well you
failed to control the Demon's unrest and now
Lucifer is involved setting up an audience for
his misguided daughter I never would have agreed
to your yearly activities I thought it would
bring trouble to our doorstep keeping Heaven
safe was my only reason for allowing it okay
okay I want you to do whatever you need to do
to keep this problem from getting any worse are
we clear yeah Adam is such a toad this Utopia is
full of lies I don't like it they sprinkles
made of rainbows Em's going to take me to a
zoo where all the animals are actually soft you
coming she's tempted by heaven but hug a koala
for me OMG can you imagine an actual koala see
you later she really hates it here I feel bad
Charlie deserves to be hey there vesaur Charlie
will be back soon you need to get out I'm not
looking for the blonde babe I'm looking for you
oh here we go maybe cuz you left the band you
tried for a solo career or I guess it's more of a
duet I don't know what you're talking about what
I wouldn't recognize one of my top girls just cuz
you're out of uniform you were on the front lines
I wouldn't forget a bad [__] like you she was
an angel warrior best thing ever vagi actually
it's pronounced vaggi no everyone's knows be call
you vaggie oh my God I was not expecting this run
now filth like you has no place in
heaven oh my God wait I was always wondering
why she was nicer than everybody else she was
originally in heaven think someone as worthless
as you landed Lilith's little hottie grats on
that I guess wow a now I love their love I
wonder what your [__] would think if she
found out you are actually one of us that's why
she didn't want to go to heaven either oh my God
it's all making sense Greg yeah I get it now
you're going to help me shut this kindergarten
snowflake [__] down for good you pompus [__]
I guess I'll just tell Little Miss butterflies
and rainbows that she's been someone who's killed
thousands of her people oh she doesn't know her
true background no she's found her at the dump
store I thought like maybe she told her the truth
about it already no this is why she said you
don't want to go to heaven she's not telling
her why we are gathered here today to determine
whether or not a soul in hell can be redeemed
into the Heavenly Realm by means of this hasbin
hotel Webster's Dictionary defines the worst
way objection lame and unoriginal I'm with uh I'm
with on this one no further dictionary references
please we have a patron angel dust oh yeah the
poor demon he's totally worth being redeemed what
do you think it takes to get into heaven um well
uh come on Adam is everything okay Adam give me
aing minute okay just got to ride out his thoughts
chat GB it act selfless don't steal Stick it to
the Man well I bet is doing all of those things
right now then let's see it bro oh no oh partying
a [__] your honors may I present exhibit a who
isn't this place the best I'll admit consent is a
good name for a sex club Nifty what are you doing
I'm sweeping nothing hellish about consent look
how hicky it is in here that's because we're
at a club yeah I thought the hotel looked
different I need a drink after today you know
Val he's in this waterboarding [__] now I don't
know it's a kink oh manad he already ruined your
whole day don't let him ruin your night too here
take one of these and you won't be worried
about nothing No Angel D you want to up all
your progress be my guest I just thought you were
better than that a I don't know it's been a long
night and I don't need to go too wild oh good
thing Heaven's watching come on you deserve a
little RNR in some THC or maybe PCP with DMT let's
see where the night takes us huh there are a lot
of abbreviations for the drugs I bought you a shot
because I bought everyone another shot another I
alcohol he likes her oh no let's do it oh no what
more do you need to see the porn star chose a KN
of debauchery that's not a soul worthy of being
in heaven it's not that bad it's not like killing
people what do you think I I I have to go to the
bathroom what faggie can you hold it faggie hold
your vaggie angel will make good decisions come
on we have to keep watching yeah I don't know yeah
let's give him a chance very well the court will
allow it [__] yes what but Adam's been saying
the f word the entire time it's like Adam lives by
different rules it's annoying next one's on Nifty
[__] like what's up with Nifty
bro you're supposed to be relaxing
not playing Nanny she ain't used to this
scene I just don't want her to end up in
the G like I used to hey he's doing the
right thing whatever nerd just catch up
when you're done God this is like our
Dynamic when we're out I'm like angel
dust I'm like who that other girl I'm Nifty
you're Cherry Bomb ni why you being such a
mess Chom like like let me be responsible for
one night oh my God you want to play with the
kitties yeah I see the club has a so I was
thinking maybe he is silly as sex with me I'm
sorry why would we have SE because I'm having
with everyone just constantly tries to justify
like no it's not it's not just for you you're
gorgeous do you need a job how many can you o
i can let's get the [__] out of here like at
once or in a row okay y drink or I'll [__]
kill you no Nifty Nifty holy [__] Angel D
you didn't get enough today funny who's this
chikita no fresh meat no I just want to taste
weird but there's a kink for that I'm sure oh
my God [__] off B excuse me I said [__] off
whoa you forget who you're talking to I own you
[__] in the studio just like like oural say
but out here I get to do what I want God damn
right enjoy the rest of your night because I'm
going to enjoy making you pay for it tomorrow
gu's such an [__] I hate him so much what
the [__] for my collection nifty's Terror
ericon he did everything on your checklist he
was selfless he stopped Nifty from stealing and
he stuck it to that Moth Man Man true then why
isn't he here then wait none of you know what
gets someone into heaven ooh we know when they
pass Divine judgment it is our job to ensure
these souls are safe fascinating but she was
right Sarah she showed us the soul can improve
he saw the light Sarah nipple chills look I got
goose iose is who's to say yeah and under what
[Music] qualifications of course and that's
why you shouldn't just be condemned forever
to hell no oh my God this might be my favorite
[Music] song this could be a Broadway musical
yeah page Escape infernal Blaze [Music]
yes and there's a lot that you don't know
SAR yeah Petty
indeed shouldn't be
only can't wait to come down and
exterminate you you go down there and kill
those the B
deal decision oh my God it's all coming [Music]
out yes girl
[Music]
yeah a little bit morals that's
what the [__] I've been
[Music]
yes this is [Music] great [__] to kill them yes
yes I was told not to trust in Angels by her oh
no oh no oh no Greg oh no they're going to OU
her did you ever think your little girlfriend
might be a liar why hide the fact that you're an
angel just like [Music] us oh oh no d different
feeling nipple chills I think those are called
[Laughter] tears this court finds that there
is no evidence souls in hell can be redeemed what
you better save the date cuz we're coming to your
hotel first what a Croc of [__] extermination
of human Souls demon or not there is no reason to
be doing this yep they were Uprising Emily it is
my position as the head seraphim to protect our
people at all costs I heard other can't just
commit acts of genocide yeah Heaven needs us
Emily and we can't doubt ourselves a worry about
the fates of demons when we have our own souls to
protect if you start to question you could end up
like Lucifer Fallen all Lucifer did was question
the man but so now we know that Lucifer isn't the
only fallen angel I'm sorry so vaggie's one yeah
so that multiple people can go that direction
but nobody can go this direction yeah come on
Greg that's not fair I cannot get over this why
why what why is it that short what I can't get
over is why you haven't bought yourself a real
reject shirt yet I can't get over that either
you know what guys it has been a miraculous year
for us but I still see there's so many citizens
of the reject Nation who have not got themselves
a t-shirt they haven't gotten one yeah surprised
so many good options there's so many good options
and they feel good do they feel comfortable the
quality of the shirt is super comfy I like to
hear yeah I love this paid her $30 more dollars
to say that no you didn't I didn't she got suck I
like the ones that are really like thick and boxy
I don't like we don't have that I know that's
what I'm saying that's why I like this one it's
like molds to me yes it's a nice quality t-shirt
it's a molding t-shirt and you know what I mean I
do know what you mean I love the shirt no well
thank you we got a whole bunch of other shirts
too and it's a great way to support the channel my
personal favorite way you can support the channel
you look good good while doing it and on top of
that too we uh for vast majority of that we are
creatively involved with them ourselves didn't
you design this one I came up with it and got an
artist to help out yes and they did a great job
it's a smart one it's it's the biggest seller I
get why I mean it's a brilliant shirt you and I
both brilliant shirt yeah my chance and Andrew
showed up to film with John in the back out said
he was weing I was like everyone's just picking
this shirt today yeah and uh yeah so thank you
guys also yourself from G feel while you're at
it because that shit's amazing I love this
episode a lot yeah this is a really good one
great music tonight great music tonight indeed uh
I love religious talks I do I found religion very
fascinating even though I'm not religious at all
I grew up religious and you know especially with
Heaven and Hell being the discussion they're
posing all these questions that I just love to
see brought to life and I I love how it there's
there's a hint there's such an irony to it where
you are seeing Heaven portrayed initially upon
First Impressions how it is uh generally portrayed
when you're kind of growing up and seeing images
of Heaven just the pearly white Gates and St Peter
there and everything is Grand and beautiful and
nothing goes bad here but you see there's all
this like political hierarchy mess uh with a lot
of unjust happening to people in Acts of genocide
and I I think the way they have found a gray like
this whole conversation was about the gray and and
then you see that heaven does not really adhere to
a gray yet there's such a gray with the with the
souls of hell and who and what qualifies someone
to be condemned forever and like they're talking
about angel dust and committing these acts of
debauchery but like what what qualifies you to
be in Hell forever like what really does you know
unless you're like a mass murderer or some [__]
you know like I don't really understand is it
about how you treat yourself or is it about
how you treat others because we see Angel treat
everybody else well yeah but himself yeah uh you
know he's poisoning himself yeah while doing
right by uh by everybody else other than his
boss who does Wrong by him you know like the boss
it's very clearly he should be in hell but there
are these people in the middle uh and it yeah
it's like the embodiment of the Pink Floyd song
right like do you think you could tell and I
don't know if some of the when they asked it
was interesting that they decid to make it when
they asked the Angels you guys don't even know
the qualifications for getting somebody in here
and then Adam names three things and while angel
dust did hit those three things those aren't
like the three things right I mean they were
just kind of random things that he spewed out but
what are the things what does make somebody good
what does make somebody evil and are the most
of are most people just somewhere in between I
think that's the whole point of it being the the
gray conversation that most people are probably
just in between and it's it's it's an unfair s
the whole concept of hell just does what they
haven't introduced yet is God right they haven't
and I feel they haven't even I don't think they'
even said the word God have they even said the
word God no the only reference that I thought we
were getting is when she when Charlie kept being
like I want to talk to the person in charge I want
to talk to the person at the top but it seems
in this world they keep bringing Adam up as the
first being here the first in heaven and it was
like first Soul the first soul in heaven and so
I thought that when we were going above Adam we
were going to go to God but in Dad we went to the
mother daughter Duo what what's the seraphim yeah
yeah yeah yeah cuz the the question that was that
has lingered in my brain for so long especially
when I did grow up Catholic and then was finding
myself going you know what maybe for me was had
a lot to do with the very concept of what hell is
you know uh like oh God is this all loving father
unconditionally loves you but if you make some
mistakes while you're on Earth you're going to
be bad vanish forever unless at the last second
you apologize yeah it's like everyone has their
opinions of it never made sense to me like but if
he's his like unconditionally loving father why
would he just banish you forever like the fiery
bits of hell this doesn't make sense to me that I
feel like that there's it contradicts itself and
and I love that the show is actually they're
full heartedly addressing um a topic that's
why I loved it so much is a it's a big debate is
what they done here and and I I think um there's
such a there's such a there's something kind of
like beautiful about putting it in a childlike
animation style because it's questioning and
challenging traditionalism and to put it in a
kind of traditionalist nostalgic type of Animation
flare just kind of further drives home that point
and uh this episode did it to such Exquisite
quality which is again great song that I think
Advance like it's so easy to pay attention to
the songs the songs are so about the narrative
yeah the lyrics are amazing the tunes are amazing
the voices are amazing they all kind of just make
you think I can't help but while I'm watching
this though there's a little voice in the back
of my head that continues to say where is Lilith
yeah of course I just the whole time I'm like is
she here is she there where is Lilith it's true I
have no idea where Lilith is where is Lilith and
and the alist Lilith connection I feel like has to
be there somehow we should um I mean yeah they've
been gone the same amount of time yeah yeah and
alistair's on somebody's leash we know that Lilith
is not with Lucifer right now and now we do know
that there is a way to get from Heaven to Hell
and Hell To Heaven wouldn't it be cool to like
disappear for a few years I sometimes have that
fantasy just disappear for a few years and then
come back and people like where you been you're
all like mysterious about it and no one really
knows would that be cool I don't feel that way
you don't feel that way you never think that way
sometimes I just want to like abandon everything
I I hope you don't feel that way often oh it's
a great feel when I think about it and I just
get lost there I'm really sorry that's tough
what sounds really tough is it not it's joyous
just leave everyone and [Music] everything yes
come on right is that rock and roll baby let us
know in the comments below this she's want to
like hide get away from it all I don't I don't
what oh man you're crazy man oh you're crazy I
got a lot of people who rely on me I couldn't
leave them oh God but imagine like not having any
responsibilities I like having responsibilities oh
what we two different people totally well I think
we know that from the start of this video because
I can't even look at you without you being upset
with me so hey that's just that's just all people
well we are clearly examples of the gray and
we're on two different ends of the gray yeah I
still accept Roxy for being the weirdo she is and
yes it is me and uh I'm glad that she understands
what normaly should look like so and she's found
it in a friend like Greg so you think you tell see
freak Heaven from Hell blue skies from pain no I
have no idea what you're doing what I could learn
this when I'm living in the woods though remember
remember all just bring Wish You Were Here Pink
F learn all these words I'm chopping down my my
wood my lumber get a big beard some people in the
comments were upset with me but I can't help
it you read the comments I always read every
comment you know that I love hearing what they
have to say and I I respond to a lot of them
you guys have been amazingly complimentary but
uh some people were upset about me continuing
to compare this to Harley Quinn yeah what the
hell but the Harley Quinn guys I cut down more
of it than you realize really the Harley Quinn
poison ivy Dynamic uh is super similar to the
Charlie vaggy Dynamic sometimes I am really
curious what Charlie's going to do now that
she knows that vagy was a angel what do
it matter I mean I think what it matter
I think what what what would she was M she was
killing Charlie's people yeah but she reformed
and she lied to her but she reformed she's
still lying how are you reformed if you're
still lying I mean yes yes but there's a
gray to it Roxy right right I think they
will eventually be okay but right now did you
not get vibes with uh Charlie and the Young
Angel as they were singing together I was like
whoa I didn't get vibes of V vaggy so you know I
I for all for all I know your gar is off I know
Harley and her already banging you know yeah um
maybe yeah well they just share a b as BFF oh
I think there's a gray there you know like she
reformed and she still she still went against what
how the Angels thought so she found herself a for
a way of Reformation as well remember that song
where she's like what am I if I'm not here for
you I think her entire identity is that Charlie
found her yeah she's being there for Charlie
but that's not real yeah but you know I I think
also the other thing that people are forgetting
Charlie's also an angel right she princess of hell
though she's princess of hell but she's also she's
she is still I don't know what to qualify is
she an angel if you're the kid of an Angel she
be like a a Nephilim or something I forget what
the word is but she would be something she mix
yeah she's mixed she is she's she's mixed she
because because her father's an angel yeah but
I don't know if you are considered an angel
if you is by your blood yeah I mean by other
other forms of mediums that I've seen that that
usually yeah if you are just every other half
angel interesting though because in this in the
world every Angel is the like if your if your dad
I'll use a different example because he's dead
if your freak if your cousin is it in hell you
talking about my dead cousin yeah whatever for
okay well go to me just because if my mom's in
heaven it doesn't make me an angel if I do bad
things then I go that's a soul though in heaven
doesn't make you an angel are you saying that
every soul here in heaven is portrayed like an
angel cuz I don't think that's what they're
saying I feel like there's like civilians
would be Spectators in the colum watching this
judg go I get what you're saying not everybody
in Heaven's an angel no she was she was before
the Council of angels there um yeah yeah yeah
I thought those were like higher Angels no
no I think it's in the same way of how like
in Hell not everyone there is like a Overlord or
some type of demonic not everyone's Alistair you
know something else I am yo yeah dude I'm here to
help you understand help me help you exactly and I
apologize for my behavior today well apologize
facing this way cuz if you apologize looking
at me I know we have a problem I apologize Roxy
that's okay should we get out of here should we
should we call each other on the phone talk next
to text and the video Ro okay [Laughter] later a
deal Chamberlain Adelia we are going to change
the lyrics of De is gone oh no to and I don't
actually know what this is about oh good I've
definitely heard the song before it's by Johnny
Cash yes and we're going to discover together
but instead of deia we going to change to aiaia
see what we did here we go okay Adelia oh Adelia
Adelia oh my my life if I hadn't shot Adelia yes
I'd have had her for my wife oh no a is gone
one more round a is gone he's shot more than
once I went up to Memphis or Nebraska wherever
you're from definitely Nebraska and I met a deia
there found her in her parlor and tied her to her
chair excellent a deal is gone for real one more
round a is gone what is happening in this song
how how many times does he shoot her she was
low down and trifling and she was cold and mean
kind of evil make me want to grab my Submachine
what adilia is gone he's going to hit you with
the chopper adilia run Adia is gone first time I
shot her I shot her in the side hard to watch her
suffer but with a second shot she died about your
evil twin Adia is gone one more round is gone
pour one out but jayer oh jayer jiler I can't
sleep you get your come upins now cuz all around
my bedside I heard the patter of adelia's feet
haunting him in the afterlife Adelia is gone one
more round round a deali is gone a throw one back
so if your woman's devilish you can let her run
or you can bring her down and do oh my God good
deal Go Johnny Go Go Johnny a is gone one more
round a is gone is gone one more round a is gone
now at your funeral I'm going to sing that in
honor of you and confuse the hell out of your
entire family I've never heard this song before
and I think this is perfect I always thought it
was about a horse until I read the lyrics it
could be like a bad horse yeah yeah yeah it's
like a devilish is devilish brood mayare or
something like that but you know clearly this
was inspired by like the the opposite traits
of you anyway I hope you're doing well and I
hope you recover from all the gunshot yes
we love you stay safe out [Music] there